hi bill so you know me as a producer if
they think and my question for you is my
favorite question on all of our guests
which is what keeps you up at night
what keeps me up at night climate change
climate change keeps me up at night
everywhere I look there are
opportunities to be addressing climate
change and everywhere I look we are not
doing it and I'm by we I mean not just
humankind writ large but my United
States where I grew up
where I went to engineering school where
I worked as an engineer trying to make
the world better for somebody and we are
missing all these opportunities it's
just crazy making and this is by the way
why I'm very proud to be the CEO of the
Planetary Society we are accomplishing
something in space we are getting things
done in space and I claim that space
exploration is good for everybody
so it's not the Apollo era we are not
devoting 10% of the world's largest
government funding to this one thing
we're spending about 0.4% be nice if it
were 0.5% but we're spending a
reasonable amount of our intellect and
treasure on learning about the cosmos
and the Planetary Society it works very
hard to direct that expenditure in what
we think is the best most efficient way
today by the way right now is the press
conference about what instruments will
be put on the Europa mission this is a
spacecraft going to the moon of Jupiter
called Europa looking to see if it's
habitable or is there a chance of living
things there such a discovery would
change the world
with that said climate change keeps me
up at night the the opportunities that
we're missing is just crazy making these
people who are in denial of climate
change well if you're a denialist and
this will probably find its way to you
and you will post these crazy
mean-spirited comments about me and
knock yourself out it's fine if that
brings you joy okay but if somebody told
you that there is no connection what
ever between smoking and cancer would
you vote for that person would that be
somebody you trust now 50 years after
that discovery was made well the
connection between humans and climate
change is about that strong and by some
very reasonable modern statistical
reckoning slightly stronger so if you're
a denier out there I strongly encourage
you to cut it out just change just get
to work there's nobody more passionate
about the environment than the guy who
just built his log cabin there's nobody
who wants you to quit smoking more
strongly than the guy who just quit or
the gal who just quit there's no more
anti-smoking advocate stronger than the
person who just quit smoking so if
you're a denier out there you could
change and we'd embrace you and we could
get to work and the opportunities are
renewable energy transmission of
electricity electricity is like magical
energy electricity storage or energy
storage and then if that's from an
engineering standpoint and then the huge
opportunity is to create a system where
people have to pay for the carbon
dioxide they create and then take those
funds that in at Treasure and redirect
it into basic research so that we can
dare I say it change the world and then
I could sleep at night